اذا في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا قال الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
ميرسي ان النصر سيكون امرا محققا اذا
التزم شركاء بلاده بوعودهم
الى ان بلاده لن تنتصر وحدها ولا يمكن ان
تقف دوله بمفردها ضد مثل هذا العدوان حسب
تعبيره وعرب عن امله في توحيد المواقف
بالامم المتحده من اجل انشاء محاكم عسكريه
خاصه لمعاقبه روسيا على جرائمها كما اعلن
الرئيس الاوكراني عزمه لقاء نظيره الصيني
هذا ونقلت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه عن وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اوليكس ان كيف تستعد لجن
هجوم مضاد بالتزامن مع مرور على الحرب من
جانبه قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائي
ان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ستنتهي دون اي
تنازلات اوكرانيه وفي مقابله مع الجزيره
بمناسبه دخول الحرب على اوكرانيا عامها
الثاني اضاف بودالياك ان هناك صيغه واحده
للسلم عرضها الرئيس اللنسكي هي خروج روسيا
من كل الاراضي التي احتلتها منذ عام 1991
قبل البدء باي مفاوضات يجب ان تقوم روسيا
بشيء واحد يجب ان تخرج تخرج من جميع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبعدها ممكن فعلا ان
نبدا باي مفاوضات حتى نتحدث عما نقوم به
فيما بعد هناك صيغه واحده للسلم هي الصيغه
التي عرضها السيد جليلسكي وتبدا هذه
الصيغه من خروج روسيا من جميع الحدود
الاوكرانيه منذ عام 91 بما فيها الدنباص
وشبه جزيره القرم
من جانبه قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
تغريده على تويتر ان اوكرانيا لن تكون
ابدا انتصارا لروسيا وان الديكتاتور
المصمم على اعاده بناء امبراطوريه حسب
تعبيره لا يمحو حب الحريه لدى الناس